SPEAKER 1: In this
Cloud Minute, I'll
show you how you can you use
Stackdriver Debugger to add
logging statements to
a running application.
I have a Python application
running on App Engine.
I've also set up
this application
in Stackdriver Debugger.
To add a logpoint, I
click on the line number
where I want to add the
log and then specify
the content of the log message.
I can reference local
variables by surrounding them
with curly braces.
I can also specify under
what conditions the message
should be logged.
I want to log every
time this point is hit,
so I'll leave it to the
default, which is true.
Now, when a user hits that path,
the message will be logged.
I can see the
results down below.
I hope you don't have any
issues that require production
debugging, but if you do,
logpoints is another great tool
to have in your toolbox.